so
i'm not sure if you're familiar i i seem
to mention this every other word
uh is i'm from the soviet union and i'm
russian
uh read way too much this is my roots
are russian too
but a couple generations back well it's
probably in there somewhere so maybe we
can uh
we can pull up that thread a little bit
of the existential dread
that we all feel you mentioned that you
i think somewhere in the conversation
you mentioned they you don't
really pretty much like dying i forget
in which context it might have been a
reinforcement learning perspective i
don't know
i know you know what it was it was in
teaching my kids to drive
[Laughter]
that's that's how you face your
mortality yes uh
from a human being's perspective or from
a reinforcement learning researcher's
perspective let me ask you the most
absurd question
what's uh what do you think is the
meaning of this whole thing
the meaning of life on this spinning
rock
i mean i think reinforcement learning
researchers maybe think about this from
a science perspective more often than a
lot of other people
right as a supervised learning person
you're probably not thinking about the
sweep of
a lifetime but reinforcement learning
agents are
having little lifetimes little weird
little lifetimes and it's
it's hard not to project yourself into
their world sometimes
but you know as far as the meaning of
life so i when i turned 42
you may know from that's a that is a
book i read um
the the hitchhiker's guide to the galaxy
that that is the meaning of life so when
i turned 42 i i had a meaning of life
party
where i invited people over and um
everyone shared their meaning of life we
they
we had slides made up and so we had we
all sat down and
did a slide presentation to each other
about the meaning of life
and mine mine was balance
i think that life is balance and um
so the activity at the party for a 42
year old maybe this is a little bit
non-standard
but i i found all the little toys and
devices that i had that where you had to
balance on them you had to
like stand on it and balance or pogo
stick i brought
a rip stick which is like a weird
two-wheeled skateboard
um i got a unicycle but i know how to
i didn't know how to do it i now can do
it i love watching you try
yeah i'll send you a video i'm not great
but i but but but i managed um and so
uh so balanced yeah so so my my wife has
a really good one
that she sticks to and is probably
pretty accurate and it has to do with
healthy relationships with people that
you love
and working hard for good causes but to
me yeah balance balance
in a word that's that that works for me
not too much of anything because too
much of anything is
iffy that feels like a rolling stone
song i feel like they must be
you can't always get what you want but
if you try sometimes
you can strike a balance yeah i think
that's how it goes
uh michael i'll write your parody it's a
huge honor to talk to you this is really
not honor i've been a big fan of yours
so um
uh can't uh can't wait to see what you
do
next in the world of uh education the
world of parity in the world of
reinforcement learning thanks for
talking today my pleasure
you